beneath all the gadgets death defying
action and beautiful women in the james
bond universe there's one dirty little
secret they don't want you to know james
bond
was never just one man
oh no james bond is just a code name for
the person who holds the world's most
dangerous job if this secret ever got
out all the evil bad guys in the world
would have a leg up on mi6 which could
threaten not only the james bond
universe but the security of the entire
world that said the truth is more
important it can't stay hidden forever
here's the thing the new bond film is
coming out in september and for those
who are new to the series a lot of
people don't understand who is james
bond he's like this 50s man going around
breaking hearts defeating evil but the
thing is the zoomers they don't care
because they need cinematic universes
explanations of how everything works
together for them to even be interested
yo dean do you watch james bond no it
kind of confuses me
let's ask jordan hey jordan who's your
favorite james bond
this is exactly what i'm talking about
jake and i've been doing some research
on james bond we've been watching some
movies we've been looking up some
youtube videos the truth is that another
film comes along and it's an entirely
different actor and they never explain
what happened to the previous actor he
doesn't die he doesn't transition title
they don't explain if it's a different
period in his life or if he got facial
surgery we're going to set out to solve
the cinematic universe and uh after a
lot of research i've got a first pass
on an edit here you're gonna love it
we can like combine this idea this kind
of like trailer-esque idea with some of
the r-rated style that we've done before
so there's all these different actors
who play bond we take some of their most
iconic action scenes and like kill them
off in sequence that that way it's not
confusing
[Music]
the first thing that stuck out to me is
the fact that i i
am now realizing how little i know about
james bond i don't know that any of that
is right in my eyes that's how it is
that makes sense to me oh now i really i
feel like i understand the bond
cinematic universe now because of that
yes it's more than just a code name of
007. james bond is part of that code
name okay so we have a pretty much
picture locked edit i went through
yesterday and just kind of fine-tuned
some things put a little extra
seasonings in there and now we're ready
to start the vfx process this list is
pretty long so we have about 36 shots to
deal with here most of them are relating
to face replacements so we have a sean
connery bond in places they shouldn't be
so that's going to require a little bit
of deep faking as well as a lot of just
extra punchy blood and guts we gotta
kill these bonds in creative ways looks
like it's kind of empty around here
problem we're facing right now we have a
lot of vfx shots but we don't have a lot
of vfx artists yeah clint's gone wren
only has one arm to work with right now
just gotten out of surgery peter's on a
extended vacation god bless his soul
it's it's up to me and that and half of
ren to make this happen we're gonna do
it though we're gonna do it because we
have faith and that's already come up
with some pretty awesome shots she's
just cranking away so maybe we should
check in with her and see how she's
doing little known fact i am also a
visual effects artist look at me react
oh
in our normal shot a grenade is pulled
on him blowing him upwards and throwing
him off the side of the mountain in
which he's totally fine because he's
protected by the bobsled that sucks
that's boring so
i put in a 3d asset that i rendered out
of octane of his arm literally flying
off just for like a little bit of
dramatic effect then we start getting to
a blood chunks so i just used the
built-in particle system in after
effects and the chunks are literally
just cubes but the body ain't made of
cubes unless you're very very careful so
you put on that turbulent displacement
which is like the cheat button in after
effects and then everything's just a
bunch of like gooey
chunks and then you just stack up a
bunch of those add some little like
spray elements and stuff in there and
then you just cover up the rest of it
with motion blur i think i did a pretty
good job for not doing this very often
[Music]
so this top hat dudes coming out of the
grave but it just looks so awkward so i
clean plated everyone just kind of
looking at the grave reinserted the
flames in the background then i found
this shot of james bond in a prison i
stabilized that footage ran it through
roto brush cleaned it up a little bit
and then that allows me to literally
just throw that shot into here and then
i added a little shadow and just a bunch
of little like quality of life things i
think it looks pretty clever so
this shot everything has been replaced
original shot he's just like shooting
the skeleton guy and he explodes for no
motivated reason here's another shot of
him just kind of like looking around i
rode it stabilized it you know the deal
he's immediately shot by himself and
then falls back into the grave what are
we working with here there's this final
i'm not really sure what i think i'm
there oh that yeah okay that looks great
i really like the little head wiggle oh
okay use the puppet tool right what if
we just cut really quick to sean connery
just like peeking his eyes out but has
he got a bullet in his head right before
we cut away oh yeah you know what i mean
it's really funny
like a freaking gopher
the james bond gun barrel sequence
it's an iconic intro in any bond movie
we have a james bond center frame inside
of a gun barrel the gun's pointed at him
ready to fire but he fires first well
not in our james bond in our james bond
the gun barrel in question fires first
and kills our sweet sweet daniel craig
now to do this we took nick and we
filmed him on a green screen wearing
very similar clothing had him fall
and from there it's just a matter of
matching not only the lighting but the
grading and there's also the shadow here
that we had to work with i think there's
two like backlights that are playing off
of him all that stuff is super important
because what we're doing is we're kind
of doing a little quick swap here it
goes from daniel craig's bond to nick
didn't even notice the switcheroo we
just pulled one over on all of them and
then all the accompaniments of blood and
guts and all that good stuff that's
actually not the hard part though the
problem that we had here was when we
shot it nick he can't just fall on a
hard surface because he's gonna you know
break his collarbone or something we
don't want two of those in the office so
we had to get him on a pad and the
problem with that is the pad has him
landing above the surface plane of our
ground how do you fix that i took a mesh
warp and we animated the legs to move up
so that he lands on a flat plane
that's pretty much that we're working on
this defect for sean connery to put him
on
whoever this guy is
not sean connor jesper christensen as mr
white all right you all know jasper
christensen
this deep fake is going to give us a an
ending where the latest james bond
daniel craig puts the nail on the coffin
on sean connery who doesn't stop coming
back for more
we're rushing it a little bit though i'd
like three days to do this new thing
i just picked up our old uh model that
we did for the luke skywalker one threw
a new face and just hit go like didn't
do anything fancy we're not doing
anything unique or neat with this one
brute force 3090 go go go and us getting
there he is like extra smooth right now
shine connor
so if you take a look around this room
we got a lot of stuff going on and a lot
of what we figured out here is from
other people sharing their knowledge
online however we had to hunt through a
lot of forums chat rooms websites
tutorials now a place like skillshare
brings it all into one spot and it's
professionally curated by people who
know what they're talking about
skillshare is an online learning
community where millions of people come
together to take the next step in their
creative journey so if you guys are
looking to get into any sort of craft be
a digital non-digital analog or you want
to do things like cook food or get
better at playing an instrument etc
skillshare is a place where you can come
together with other people to learn new
things it's awesome it doesn't matter if
you're a professional or a beginner or
just looking for a hobby skillshare has
it covered there's a combination of
video lessons and class projects on
skillshare and they have classes that
fit your schedule and skill level
members get unlimited access to all the
classes hands-on projects and feedback
from a community of millions most
classes are under 60 minutes with short
lessons so that they fit your time frame
sam's like my personal tutor for virtual
production because i'm learning how to
make stuff in unreal engine
i've been waiting like five minutes to
do that
skillshare actually has a class for
virtual production unreal engine by
cinema captures you guys should check it
out if you are looking to get into
virtual production because not everybody
has a sam who can just learn it all
beforehand and just teach you if you
guys would like to try out skillshare
for yourself well there's a link in the
description below and the first thousand
people to click it will get a free
premium skillshare membership trial so
go check it out you got nothing to lose
and if you don't like it
oh well
try later
so there's this moment in the james bond
movie goldfinger where the man with the
golden finger is about to kill james
bond with a laser because he's strapped
down to the table he can't go anywhere
here's the problem though the filmmakers
when they originally made this movie
made a huge mistake they accidentally
didn't kill james bond in the scene so
we've got to rectify that that laser
cuts him in half we need to deliver on
his death in the laser beam so the first
idea had was it'd be cool to have his
head separate into two different
elements the first one i can just easily
rotoscope out his head he turns to the
right and that i can just make it look
like it turns and slides off to the
right what remains is his original head
so you got to cover half of it like this
i basically just like went online and
found a cross section of like a skull
and brains and comps it together added
some charred textures added a little
like charred tongue slice okay so then i
went through and i rotoscoped his whole
chest and arms and then i masked out
just the middle of that and then using
some liquify just like kind of like
stretched it out so yeah i can literally
just like take his torso here and like
move it around so now i actually
separated his body
i tracked the little diode here i
dropped in video copilot saber for the
laser i matched it to the original laser
in the movie and once i got pretty much
all of that kind of into place then i
was able to start adding sparks fire
elements smoke
fun action vfx has like the best library
for modern visual effects elements like
that so yeah i mean i've got a couple
more things to like spice it up you
gotta like garnish your your meal just a
little bit like
let's serve the beef
[Music]
all right so i've been training this
deep fake now for about six days uh we
actually had a cataclysmic gradient
collapse
it's trying to achieve closer and closer
approximation of a face and it went
whoop and just became a blue square but
the move video got delayed so that was
cool and that gave me time to train this
all over the weekend so now we have a
really nice looking sean connery deep
fake so on the left we see jasper the
actor his face from the actual movie on
the right we see the ai reconstruction
and you notice they're pretty dang good
so we've managed to encode his face
pretty decently now the challenge here
is decoding his face as sean connery you
know like the colors will dial in later
but like the details looking pretty
solid and you know all of our sean
comedy shots are being pulled from old
films you know it's only going to be as
high res is what we have there so
basically i'm going to take this i'm
going to merge it onto the footage and
we'll have ourselves the final deep fix
shots you're going to be able to tell
the deep fakes it'll still be fun it's
not about being flawless it's about
having a good time
we have a video coming out oh hey guys
i'm here for james bond man it's been uh
quite a long road from conceptualizing
to where we are now i think we have a
pretty solid bond rated star it's a bond
murder highlight reel is what we're
going for today so the hope is that this
video that you're about to see will live
forever on the internet and whenever
someone types in history of james bond
this will be the first thing that shows
up
[Music]
you expect me to talk oh mr bond i
expect you to die
are you forgetting one thing if i fail
to report another bond replaces me
i trust he will be more successful
what are you doing what are you doing oh
oh no no
well at least he died on the job
from now on all remaining agents and
trainees be known as james bond double o
seven including the girls well that'd be
really confusing so exactly the enemy
won't know which way to turn my name's
bond james bond
[Music]
my name is lana
james bond
[Music]
looks like you have about two seconds to
live
my name's bob
james
[Music]
knock knock [ __ ]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
the key to a woman's heart is an
unexpected gift
name's bond
james bond
[Music]
bond here
yes of course i'm back
i've just tweeted an apology
huh
[Music]
her name's bond
james bond
yeah
i hope everyone's all caught up now on
the bond series so that we can jump into
this new yeah movie it's really like
amped me up for daniel craig now do you
like james johnson
go get him daniel transitions were
really creative the gravestone motif was
really good but honestly the best
absolute best part is sean connery
coming back from the dead and then being
sniped and falling back down that was
executed really well that's snapshots
the hardest thing with these recuts is
making the edit a cohesive one one that
like actually tells a new story like a
truly new story that's unexpected with
footage you've seen before
so from jake
matt and all of us here who worked on
this cut i hope you guys enjoyed us uh
bringing james bond into a cinematic
universe we like to make a lot of things
r-rated we've done home alone we've done
willy wonka one of my personal favorites
so leave a comment down below and let us
know which movie we should
screw with next